la maschera per carità niente una
discarica e oggi non ci fa bene ti sei
già abbonato
sì è vero aggiunge che ci avete script è
richiesto in tanti si cela fumetti in
continuazione sotto il video che bucano
mi chiede sempre il file altre corone di
decorazione challenge by da tre colori e
decorazioni quando abbiamo deciso di
organizzare innanzitutto grazie mille
per avercela consigliata accadendo
se volete consigliate cene altre nei
commenti in pratica come funziona come
la trans come la tre colori di colla
slime challenge però in queste cose sono
tre colori di decorazione di piacermi
nella bolla bendati dovremmo scegliere
una scatola qualsiasi scatola ci capita
dovremmo versare tutto il contenuto
nella notte
tutta la scala con certi filmini alberto
detenuti voluto prendere ecco che tutto
ciò in questo caso del sì sono tutte le
decorazioni in base al colore ad esempio
questo solo decorazioni rosa solo viola
solo ce ne sono eccetera
e questo grigio sono grigie dove bros
allora prima non avevo una scatola rossa
cosa si possono cambiare tempio
qualsiasi play
così sono dei pigmenti insomma cambiano
in parte dal colore pescato le diverse e
mischiare i tre colori assieme questo
caso ci sono tutte cose che non mi
piacciono di più questo è vero che
capita ad esempio il resto le scaglie
verdi come ti piacciono però i colori
assieme e sperare che non è stato un
colore difetta tipo creda o marrone e
verde scuro insomma dobbiamo vedere che
colore esse sono troppo curioso perché
il suo stacco dispiaciuto delle frazioni
tutti i colori tiene frati mettetevi
cosi prenditi un bel live se volete
vedere altre challenge 1 milione allora
primo
si canta
[Musica]
allora bene bene bene tutto pronto farlo
mamma mia che parla così mangia tristi
mantenimento
allora io devo rischiare le scalzone
canta una canzone mischiano a cantare
[Musica]
regola non devi toccare la scatola
cercando di capire la forma parentele si
capisce mariano benito generali ricordo
saluto in quella diritto a cavallo tomba
c'era il rosso e con l'avere di di che
forma è la rai contro il werder c'erano
altre cose non era cartevalori dentro
così si vestono come da me comunque devi
solo fermarti dove vuoi per mare la mano
che allora dammi la mano le scatole
storo sicurezza centro dove sono e ce
n'è anche un alla fine trovava aspettare
vicino forse non ci arrivo ok d'acqua in
acqua quale sei questa sei sicura di
fusione ok ai 7 il cuore blu
come riporta blu per vitale dopo andiamo
a mettere tutto il problema prima per
scarico quindi vado a vent'anni e
mischiare vai a pescare c'è l'impatto
parla di mido le scatole sono qui e qui
da qui ho paura del burden over the no
perderò verde non mi richiamare sento
che mi sta tirando la maledizione del
perde neanche sarà questa molto bene
aspettati d'orgoglio la maschera
[Musica]
hai detto tu mi perdo mi sta richiamando
vecchia ballo non ci posso credere al
primo turno ma non mi stima raggiungere
di scudetto ma vede davvero presa
dall'ira altri senso del turno le scelte
bellissimo io avrò tutto bene vitale
tutto blu spiega però se ti capita la
scatola gialla dopo diventato trovate
anche il tuo bacheca picchiandola i
primi capi di gioco 2000 classica che
per quello io signor michael bene cosa
può capitare
capita in rosso cosa diventa una buona
ma noi andiamo a svuotare la nostra
mistery box preparata nell'onda jma del
viso klaver edizione abbiamo la colla r
almeno i glitter gialli dentro voglio
vedere prevedere poi con la di tiger
glitterata verde scuro quindi non mi
salvo proprio tutto verdissimo e poi
questi criteri anche in altri anziano
che non piacciono per niente così cosa
al primo giorno tutto sembra buco di
trollo tipo quello di harry potter è
remota
la ricotta al mente un po evidenziatore
almeno andare in prigione per del
bellissimo verde verde diventerà poi
questi glitter scorgono tanto carini
sono un po bianchi non sono bertini e
poi il clay lo andiamo a mettere dopo
che lo sa darmi attivato perché avete
visto che in genere quando lo mettiamo
prima succede un disastro se invece lo
mettiamo dopo uscita una sorta di
butterfly
l'effetto è bellissimo perché super
glitterato a tantissimi niente
bellissimo sul sito che ti piace sarà il
primo ingrediente da noi siamo abbiamo
la colla disperata blu scuro e poi lo
mandavo la mia preferita la pallina
bilocali
no di spot bellissimi come nome bianca
di san bellino e via de gaspari per lui
è uno dei colori preferiti vitale quindi
è felicissimo di avere tutto allora
cominciamo è troppo belli i film io noi
andiamo ad aggiungere l'altra colla
macola che i glitter che i colori
rafforzerà ancora di più il colore
diventerà bellissimo poi mettiamo questi
tramite che non mi piacciono
iniziamo pochi che c'è un foglio intero
lato non mi piacciono ultimamente in
piazza non note nei commenti come no non
piace solo ai visto che bei colori che
coi colori stupendi e ora passiamo al
secondo round ha vinto quattro colori
carica parole stato sempre un male
[Applauso]
[Musica]
in sostanza come detto da forme tutto
promettono per cento non pupilla con il
giallo giallo blu cosa uscirà questo non
è giusto che mai ma non daranno i
cadaveri burke italia un raid merde
merde cosa c'è stata
rosso tel citerò navale le camere per
finire terrosa viola risultato bene ci
sei
potete vedere tutto questo allora è
questa ogni modo che ha toccato qualcosa
ma non so se non posso non sicure questa
va bene cosa sono prendendo prima questo
quindi non a caso non è messa al centro
costa magica allora nella tavola abbiamo
la colla rosa che poi abbiamo le palline
rosa tutti anche il mio fianco
speriamo poi abbiamo sempre i cosiddetti
che non piace una fitta rete di perrotta
poi il pigmento rosa perché quando lei
quindi se il pigmento quindi spero che
il pigmento mente farlo cambiare di
colore superiamo quel girone col
pubblico esistono questi glitter eno in
forma di stili primato verde per
fortissimi genova ma niente ma che
cavolo ma mettiamo il pigmento strano
errore se questi non cambieranno ancora
purtroppo ma un carinissimo sopra
lo rendono ancora più carino nera non so
franci e forse contribuiranno a dare ha
detto che ne metti poche perché poi
ricadono tutte queste sì forse non fanno
rumore però vediamo un po almeno le
palline gli stanno dando un aspetto più
carino persone salite guardano che viene
del resto se un po di rosa il bottino ma
anche lettori ne stanno cambiando colore
com'è possibile che anche palline stanno
diventando marrone delicato decor
scaduta a buffet
vediamo il flirt giallo che lo mettiamo
dopo abbiamo detto lo mettevo poi
abbiamo la colla già con le paillettes e
poi le palline gialle non avevo visto
c'è anche questo è l'altro lettore
laziale prime libere
mettiamo poco poco un altro po trash e
ma sempre veramente poco codino
direttore niente diventa più bello del
mio verde non è possibile
prendete tutte le mafie reati ma come
scusa allora ho messo tutto ci manca
solo che crei che lo mettiamo dopo
chiudere e di che non è diventato
diventato verde ancora più blu blu blu
blu blu per i riflessi verdi verde no
noi perché l'acqua dalle palline sono
rimaste blu e celeste acqua guarda e
celeste ancora tenuto benissimo si trova
benissimo che fa acqua non puoi più
pazzini e celeste acqua maturo
bellissimo e ora partiamo dall'ultimo
turno ed ora sono rimasti sono due
scalcione cosa vuol dire questo che chi
pesca resterà per sé e poi l'altra
scatola andrà all'altra persona senza
che la scelta cf è piaciuto viola e
rosso visto che mi capiti viola non erro
parole vi capiti di diametro il rosso
speriamo bene
carta farmi si è capito dai fai
come facciamo allora nella mia scatola
abbiamo inteso rosso che non so come
usciva mischiato col des offerte
veramente non lo sto ovviamente la prole
ma devo ammetterlo dopo poi palline
rosse con la rotta che è molto bella da
scuola ma mischiata non lo so e l'altra
cosa che interessa altro ecco perché
avevamo lei vino da quando tutto e tutti
che il 77 di età né audience fishbowl
brava dello zoom l'immagine è stata
bella ma con 52 alla glitter rosta che
ancora più scura esami schiavi vediamo
che colori diventando
mandare in effetti sta diventando un bar
vicino magazzino verde per almeno ci
sono le palline rotta forse di palline
rosse lo stanzieranno vedendo l'altro
non ho mai mischiato il click con uno
slide con le palline quindi non ho idea
di come uscirà fuori butter con le
palline che strano dove però tutti i
mezzi dopo
ma le mettiamo per niente per me
rispetto a come diventa letto io era già
bellissimo così visto che bello vedere i
colori bellissimi quindi abbiamo la
folla viola carico guardian detenuti non
ho visto che c'era un canestro
e poi abbiamo questo piccolo ne vuole a
mio nome fischia e poi ci mancava questo
che non avevo visto né un lampione
questo è un lampione mettiamo questi qua
che sono prodotti i siti web dei faretti
stato mica saranno tutti i sensi nuovo
con diametro possono spalmare
promettiamo il provare lampione e poi
infine mettiamo la colla viola magari
che seppur essere fortunati ad essere
veramente un po kalac nel certo che
bello no non mi dire che diventa moran o
quattro giorni
no no diventa galaxy workshop e una
galaxy più galassie diurno vediamo
grazie no a grigio il diritto di grillo
non è più butterato il mio
rosso rosa fisso rosa è tuo e più scuro
blu e giallo no aggiunto kubrick
dobbiamo vedere come verrà fuori una
volta attivato il cosplay per ora
andiamo ad attivarlo è che facciamo
vedere prima attivo normale e poi da voi
andremo a mettere il claim qui siete
pronti abbiamo tutti anche nei ragazzi
ecco qua il lime allora vini rossi
tufino sorta di marroncino parola musica
però almeno silvio del rosso e rota che
sono molto carini l'ho lasciato un
pochino appiccicoso potete vedere perché
ora andiamo ad aggiungere il play così
almaric lei si amalgama meglio comunque
finora cosa ne pensate status line e un
po franci sentitissimo di verità allora
andiamo ad aggiungere prima il clay ha
preso con un pezzo rosso allora
innanzitutto il cre della dei suoi
morbidissimo sembra già di giocare con
batte slime super morbido supersoffici
wow quindi iniziamo mischiando questo
nome né finito un po sotto le unghie va
bene un magnete mischiamo questo
[Musica]
avrà diventerà un pò rosa magari vediamo
se diventano un pò rock un pò rosa
subito il colore migliore ma purtroppo
non è finita qua perché sapete per cui
devo aggiungere il clay verde purtroppo
questo è rimasto super morbido e sta
diventando rosa che bene hanno il colore
molto cittadella dei e dopo che
aggiungerà inferte diventerà vedremo
comunque la colorato tantissimi infatti
stessa bellissimo e ora purtroppo
inserirebbe è molto chiaro come verde
quindi li metterò marrone chiaro ma
vediamo la mettiamo col sente un po
difficile ma dopo lo mette un'altra pole
istituzione per letta siamo perché
pizzico vediamo come diventa con il mend
vi è un po dai forse non prende troppo
il colore vediamo lo stesso pur essendo
il rosso rimane comunque molto forte
ancora sentite che fuori quindi penso
che sia praticamente spront è un mix tra
un battere un crunch ad ora il credo
martin per numeri pazzo un mix tra poter
vitale che si sta mettendo a rischio
weimar e non avevo mai fatto né mai
visto un mix tra battere craxi invece
sono pure dei fishbowl dentro comunque
alla fine il colore finale e non è molto
male dai non è proprio marrone non è
proprio verde non è rosea
boh secondo me che colore è questo
questo è il risultato del mio slime una
sorta di rosa antico forse come di
piazze mi piace la consistenza un pò
buffer un po cranici
quindi questo è il mio slime vediamo ora
curiosi vitale un altro già da allora
ecco il mio slime allora fermi tutti
devo dire una cosa devo spiegare che
cosa sia 16 giga
apparentemente sembra grigio ma non lo è
via che in realtà se guardate bene
facciamo un po di zoom sembra grigio ma
in realtà è blucelesti non chiaro verde
acqua però in realtà sembra grigio ma
non lo è
crede da una parte sono contento che o
il clay credilo vado subito da
aggiungere voglio dire che anche il mio
è un po un pochettino mollaccione e
quindi lo aggiungo il clay tutto a
prezzi così si dovrebbe secondo la mia
testolina mischiare elio
non garantisco però è diventato stai
proprio fortunati ma certo più di 100
l'abito e poi aggiungeremo ma non
diventerà verde e un po appiccicosa non
riesca e uffici cosa bisogna pubblicare
tutto aiuto come graziella che vuoi dire
guardate dove devo andare rispetto a
quella sulla fragola scaduta versa idee
e bellissima adesso mettiamo il giallo
per un attimo a staccarmi seguito questo
slime che andiamo ad aggiungere il
critichiamo come diversa aperte ma quale
verde un nome di la serata è nell'uomo
in certe sfumature nei sfumature dal
futuro è verde
ma che bello è certa abbiamo aggiunto un
po di soluzione
alla fine ho preso il verde come scatola
ma mi diverto il colore è quello che è
diventato il tuo pur non avendo ho preso
la scatola verde effettivamente c'è la
zona e la consistenza di questo slim
stranissima batte al franchi è davvero
davvero assurdo ci siamo quasi
il batterlo davis palmare con le dita
attendere però dai normale è miss mio la
terra il possiamo paragonare il mio
stupendo famosi che entrambe infatti al
craxi un pezzetto l'altro si sono
rilassati che bello quindi quale vi
piace di più
se vi inserita servizio e vittorio mete
italiane vi piace di più potete sapere
se volete rivedere una sala del genere o
consigliate silenzi che vorreste vedere
perché 14 cappellino subito il calo per
vedere i nostri altri video le nostre
challenge video divertenti